all right thank you very much for
attending this and thank you for the
introduction so so I'm going to be
talking about allocating resources in
the future the first question which
should arise in all of your minds is
what the hell do I mean by that and I'm
going to spend some time explaining that
before I get on to the main set of topic
of my talk
essentially this problem is about online
decision-making as opposed to sort of
the online learning problems that
Umbridge was talking about so kind of
more in the vein of what Lina was
talking about and most of the talk is
going to focus on this very very simple
sort of canonical example of online
decision-making so what I have is a
single resource here I've sort of
indicated that resource in this box and
the resources atomic so think of these
as maybe seats on an airplane I start
off with three units of this resource
and now I have a sequence of agents who
are showing up who want who are
interested in getting one unit of this
resource each now each agent has a
certain type and in this case the agent
wants one unit of the resource but
they're offering some value for if I
give them if I allocate that one unit
when the agent shows up I know the type
so the first agent has showed shown up
and that person tells me theta one and
at that point I need to make an
irrevocable decision so I look at that
person's offer and I say no I will not
allocate the resource on the other hand
if I do decide to allocate the resource
then this is non replenishable so think
of this as again airline seats if not
United you can't resell it so that's a
very very standard setting which
hopefully many of you would have seen in
various guises before and in some sense
what makes these settings interesting is
okay what is the assumption that we make
on the agent types and the the
fundamental assumption I'm going to make
in this talk is that the set of types is
finite this is not crucial but to some
extent this matters for us and to kind
of
anchored this entire thing in um in your
mind I'm one example to keep in mind is
that maybe each agent has some value VI
and it's drawn iid from some with some
probability P I from a finite set of
this finite set of values however that's
I mean clearly uninteresting if you're
kind of selling if you are trying to
sell seats on an airplane you know that
the arrivals are going to be time
varying it's going to be less at in the
beginning towards the end maybe people
want to pay more etc it may actually be
correlated depending on maybe there's
some event and people may want to pay
more for the event and we want to sort
of try to capture these sort of or the
phenomena but the basic question that we
want to answer is given the set of
setting how do i allocate resources to
maximize the sum of rewards that I
collect make sense okay so admittedly
this is an extremely simple model but um
in some sense the work that we done
talks to sort of - just much more
widespread generalizations of this so
one way of generalizing this is to think
of having multiple resources which are
not in some sense compatible so here I
have these two resources again keeping
with the same metaphor think of this as
a flight going from here to Newark and a
flight going from Newark to Ithaca and
now each agent requires a subset of
resources so if I'm going back home I I
really need to see two new out but I
don't want to be stranded at Newark um I
want another flight to go to Ithaca and
I'm willing to pay a certain value if I
get that subset and if and only if I get
that subset of resources right so this
AI now is think of it as a zero one
vector which indicates which resources I
want could be combinatorial and VI is
again the value so the type space sort
of includes both the resource that I
want and the value that I'm offering for
that so this again kind of comes up in
many different fields if you if you are
in operations research you would have
seen this as what's called network
revenue management for certain
historical reasons um if you are from
more of an economics or AGT background
you would have you would think of this
as selling to a single-minded bidder but
this is the basic online packing problem
so this is one way of generalizing this
where I'm saying each person who shows
up wants a set of resources and is
offering the
single value the other way is kind of
like an ore so everyone we again have
different resources each one has their
own initial capacities but now each
agent wants exactly one research but
they have different values for it so
staying with the same metaphor this
could be the morning flight to it the
car this could be the crazy sort of the
late night or the red-eye flight most
people would have less value for the
red-eye flight some people who are crazy
like me maybe prefer taking it so each
one comes in and says I have this much
value for each of these resources but
they just want one I don't want to buy a
seat for the morning and the red-eye and
again depending on which community you
come from you either think of this as
online weighted matching and whichever
surrounding give a beautiful talk on
this earlier in the workshop in ADT this
would be called selling to a unit demand
bidder and these are sort of kind of two
ways of generalizing just the basic
canonical setting that we are looking at
is there any questions about this so
this is the main setting that I'd be
considering I'm hoping most of you have
seen some version of these kind of
problems before so there's a huge
literature in thinking about these
generic problems I have kind of just
like flashed a few ways of approaching
it again in the our OEM community this
there's this whole field of what's
called revenue management which thinks
about how do you do pricing when you
know people want certain resources and
you know something about the future and
you have limited resources this is the
same set of problems are tackled if
you're in enough online algorithms and
in approximation algorithms um that this
is one way of doing it using primal-dual
approaches but there's many ways of
approaching this um there's a beautiful
set of bootcamp talks from a previous
Simon's workshop on what are called
profit inequalities is by Commissioner
Gillen and Matt Weinberg and the profit
inequality is again one way of kind of
talking about these problems now on the
other hand there are also a hierarchy of
informational variants on this problem
so it depends like in different settings
you know different amounts about what's
going to happen in the future the sort
of thing I'm going to is talking about
is more about adversarial inputs where
you don't want to assume
anything about the future arrivals but
this the spectrum sort of goes all the
way to having full information about the
distribution of the soft generative
model of the future arrivals or
something in between where you know
there's a generative model maybe you
know the structural form of the model
but you want to try and learn the model
as you serve go along so I'm gonna live
somewhere closer to this side but in a
more general than just iid just to sort
of situate what where the stock is going
and again so at this point you should be
sort of asking that okay all of this is
this is really really beautiful theory
but it exists in some sense so the
second sense in which I want to talk
about allocating resources in the future
is I want to self start asking the
question well so moving forward given so
the new technology that we have um how
is resource allocation going to change
and and the primary the primary thing
I'm interested in is this question so as
we look around us we are getting better
and better at sort of looking at data
and predicting from that we don't
completely understand how we are doing
it we are sort of learning generative
models which we shouldn't be able to
learn using standard theory but we're
getting extremely good at sort of
somehow figuring our generative models
and using these to do prediction now
this is not a talk per se about learning
and the way I'm going to kind of exhibit
is this is as follows so I'm going to
assume for parts of the talk that I have
access to some sort of a black box
predictive algorithm so I have someone
has built a beautiful predictive
algorithm and they've given it to me and
I'm going to ask it certain queries I
get some answers from the black box
hopefully they're good answers and I
want to use these answers to guide how I
want to do resource allocation and so in
some sense what this talk is getting at
is if we have all of this beautiful
machine learning and data mining which
is available for us how do we kind of
take it and put it into thinking about
resource allocation is there some
meaningful way of doing that and what
I'll try to convince you is that by
taking this viewpoint we actually get
some interesting news policies which
have very strong guarantees but to some
extent even if you don't believe this
hype about the machine learning and the
in predictions there is a when we
started off we didn't kind of take this
perspective but it turned out that a
real re-examining these old settings
lead to very surprising new insights
even if you don't care about the black
box prediction side of it so that's what
this so that's the serve two senses of
allocating resources in the future that
I want to talk about okay this is so we
have a this of joint work with my
collaborator Alberto Vera one of those
two pictures is my collaborator the
other one is the inspiration for this
book the Reverend base I will let you
guess which and for the rest of the talk
I'm going to self focus on this earth
combinatorial allocation setting so this
is the network revenue management
setting where that these two flights
certain people want to buy seats on both
flights someone else wants to buy seat
on a single flight each person offers me
a certain value for buying this this
bundle of seats I know all of this
information when they come in and I know
the distribution or I know some sort of
generative model about what the future
values at the future types are and again
I want to decide I have I have some
initial capacities these exhaust at the
end of time and I want to decide how to
allocate any questions about the setting
because from now and I'll sort of start
talking about what we do okay good so
now this part is perhaps for the expert
if you've but it's worthwhile knowing
that in a setting like this specially if
I tell you that these these types are
being drawn iid with some known
distribution P I there is a notion of an
optimal algorithm so this is what's the
subclass of what's called a Markov
decision process and we know how to
compute the optimal solution to this via
via dynamic programming you've not seen
this before it's not very important in
some sense this talk is trying to
address the question that we don't want
to like there are reasons why we don't
want to think about dynamic programming
it's complex it requires exact knowledge
but for me at least what's more
important is it does not actually
quantify give or it does not give us
some sense of what was the use of
knowing the
future information or what was the use
of having good predictive models so what
I'm gonna compare against instead is
what's called the profit benchmark and
the idea here is in some sense the best
I could do is always bounded by what I
could have done if I knew the entire
sample path which was coming so if I
knew all the future arrivals I could
have taken all that into account while
making my decisions and what I want to
ask is what how much do I lose if I
don't know that information so kind of
to formalize this a little more you can
if I told you all the arrivals from now
till the end of time you can actually
write down this allocation problem as an
integer program so here for each type I
so remember there were n types it's a
finite set of type so for each type I
I'm deciding how many of that type to
accept everyone who I accept gives me
some value VI but they take some they
have a vector of resource allocations AI
and so the sum of all the resources I
allocate should be less than the vector
of resources I started off with and
these guys should be integers but they
should also be less than the number of
people who came in so all of this is
deterministic this thing here is a
random quantity it is the number of
arrivals of type I from now to the end
of time I'm assuming I know this Rachele
at least for the offline problem I'm
assuming I know this information and the
way the kind of benchmark I'm going for
is I'm still calling it regret but this
is the subtle difference from what
Ambaji was talking about which is that
here I'm going to look at what how much
I achieve and how it differs from what
this offline algorithm achieves in
expectations because this is a random
variable but this is not comparing
against sort of a small class of
policies this is truly the optimal like
this you cannot beat this this is the
true upper bound on anything I could do
I want to see how far away am i from
this offline optimal in an additive
sense
um
so here is kind of the main algorithmic
idea for in the entire talk so as I
mentioned before I'm going to assume I
have a this black box predictive or
occur with my the data science team has
built this beautiful machine and given
it to us and what I want to do is I
wanna query this Oracle about the
performance of this offline algorithm so
in particular I'm going to ask the
Oracle this following question so at any
time T so I am at the current state and
I have a certain current budget level
for my a vector of budgets for all my
resources and someone arrives and says I
want this this and this research and I'm
willing to pay you so much so what I
want to do is I want to go to my black
box predictive Oracle and ask them well
okay can you predict if I decided to
accept or if if we decided to accept
this current arrival what's the
probability that the value of the
offline solution from now till the end
of time will actually decrease on the
other hand what's the probability so
what's the sort of measure of a sample
parts we're accepting the current
arrival kind of always leads to a
suboptimal outcome and then on the other
hand what sort of the remaining
probability is for the sample parts were
accepting the current arrival may lead
to or will lead to the optimal outcome
but we don't know how does this query
make sense so I'm at a current state I
know my current budget level I go to my
black box predictor and ask them what's
the probability if I accept the current
arrival the offline value actually
decreases
now if you think a little about it if I
had access to a query of this sort
there's actually a very very natural
policy which I can implement and I was
just mentioning to umbrage
the first time I heard of the base
selector was oddly enough in a class
which I'm which taught bark in UT Austin
when he was a postdoc so so what is the
base selector well so this is actually a
simpler problem in learning theory the
idea is let's say you're trying to
predict a sequence and you know that X
is being drawn from a bernoulli with
some bias P if you had some estimate of
the bias P hat then the best thing to do
to try and predict the sequence and
match it as often as possible is to just
try is to threshold P hat so you take P
hat if it's more than 0.5 you output a 1
if it's less than 0.5 you just output a
0 and what I'm suggesting is well I
would like to copy off line as often as
possible I have some prediction about
what off line is doing the best thing I
can do in order to copy it is to take
this prediction and just threshold it
this is at least one possible thing I
could do does this make sense and so
here's kind of the main theorem that we
have so what we can show is underserve
Airy mild tail bounds on this this
distribution that ni the number of
arrivals of each type till the end of
time we can show that this algorithm the
base selector actually has regret which
is independent of the horizon and it's
actually also independent of all the
budget levels so it depends on the
complexity of your problem if you have
more resources yes it's going to get
worse that should be true because the
generality in which I stated the problem
you could encode things like vertex
cover independent set but it does not
depend on the number of arrivals and it
does not depend on the number of budget
levels I have and the nice thing is this
actually all works even if the arrivals
that I'm varying if they're correlated
with some version of this works even if
you have discounted rewards it works for
all the settings that I mentioned
single-minded unit demand etc and you
should be worried at this point that ok
all of this is nice but even computing
that probability should be really hard
but it works even if you have of an
approximate version and in
what I'm really gonna prove is not this
theorem but I'm going to prove that
there is a easy way of constructing an
approximate Oracle which gives this
bound and that kind of implies this for
the true Oracle as an aside yeah ok so
that's what the rest of the talk is
about so any questions about just what
the policy is and what the guarantee
yeah
so that means online learning first that
black box is equivalent to offline
yes okay there's a subtlety here that
I'm sort of assuming that so one way of
getting this black box would be that you
look at past data and you learn this but
but this is a very easy event to learn
so you let's say you had some past data
and you build some model for some
generative model you could just simulate
and check for this right you could just
simulate ahead and say hey what's the
probability I accept or not so it's not
I don't want to say anything about
online learning but in some sense it's
saying if I had data from the past I
could use that build us a very simple
simulator which would answer these
queries it data driven samples right
they are not IND yes I am NOT so that's
why I am being agnostic of how I get
that probability I'm saying maybe in the
past you observed so you can observe the
arrivals and I'm not affecting okay it's
important that I'm not affecting their
arrivals my decisions affect how much
revenue I make but it doesn't affect who
comes in tomorrow asking for a resource
and maybe I have some past data about
who came and asking for what resource
and I just used that to build these
generative modules so then oh okay
another way of saying it is there are
externalities in the problem except that
this bounded resource I'm not by taking
my decisions at the moment I am NOT
affecting the future a lot of this would
extend but yeah at least not for this
talk any other questions
okay so the rest of the talk is mostly
sort of giving an idea of why this is
surprising and also how we kind of prove
something of this sort but just any
questions and the basic setup and
like the policy okay cool so things will
get a little technical from now but I'll
try to keep give you a sense of how you
prove so or why why this was not known
but also how you prove something like
this so if you so this is the thing I'm
trying to compete against this was this
integer program where I it it's a random
variable because it's sort of dependent
on the random number of people who show
up but if I knew this I could solve this
program exposed and decide what I want
to do now one common way to try and
approximate this is to take this problem
and then replace this with the expected
number of people who show up in each
type so I'm sort of taking exactly that
problem and I'm saying hey the only
randomness was in this ni of T so I'm
going to replace that with the expected
value if it's iid that's just T times P
I now this is depending again on which
community you come from called different
things in stochastic controls this is
often called the fluid LP and there's a
very easy sort of Jensen's concavity
argument which shows that this fluid LP
is actually an upper bound on this
optimal solution the optimal exposed
solution one way of seeing this is if
you think in the dual space all the
randomness is in the objective function
of the dual so the dual polytope is
fixed so you're just doing minimization
over a set of corner points and so
that's concave um anyway and so what
this suggests is this suggests a very
natural policy which is I look at this
the optimal solution to this fluid LP
and then I reinterpret X I / T times P I
as a probability of accepting this type
and I just whenever type I shows up I
look at this probability and I accept
with that probability does it make sense
so this is often called randomized
admission control or RAC it's been
studied very extensively in the past and
there is a seminal result by go and
fundraise and back in 97 although I yeah
where as far as I know they first show
that this has a regret which grows a
square root of T so it the regret is
sub-linear but it is sort of approaching
the optimal at a rate of square root of
T
which is kind of what you would expect
in any setting like this so the same
sort of thing I'm butch was suggesting
an and there is follow-up work sort of
extending this to more general settings
in particular this work because the
smugglers and collaborators um but one
side of the important thing to note is
that this is kind of it's still a really
beautiful result because there is a
purely static policy of never changing
the prices but I'm still getting
vanishing regret just by using this
fluid LP but on the other hand this kind
of the buck stops here you cannot sort
of do better than square root tea by
doing this method yeah so this would
assume regular distributions so the
monotone hazard rate let's say so
decreasing increasing hazard rates I
think it can extend this pert
it's a a very natural thing to do at
this point is to say well by choosing a
static policy you're just kind of
leaving a lot on the table you know how
you are you know how things are are
changing over time maybe you should use
that somehow in your heuristic and a
very natural idea if you think a bit
about it is well why don't you take this
way of constructing the fluid LP and do
this at each time with whatever your
current budget level is and whatever
your prediction is of like the to go
value that's a kind of really natural
thing to do this is often called the
resolved fluid LP and and you do the
same policy at each time you sample or
you accept with probability X I divided
by the expected value of the to go this
surprisingly actually doesn't work in
many cases so there's been a it this has
been widely studied there's a lot of
work trying to think about when this
works when this doesn't work and kind of
building up to this really seminal
result by Marty Raymond and general
where they showed that if you do this
carefully you don't do this every time
but you do this at very carefully chosen
intervals then you can improve the
regret to small over square root T and
then later there was a series of works
I'm including this one by a Justin and
Kumar where they showed that under
certain conditions I'm what I'm calling
dual in on degeneracy it's not very
important what this is but um there are
certain settings so certain sort of
parameter values under which you can
probably show this gets order one regret
so it does get constant regret but
there's what's what this is hiding is
that that constant is actually affected
by how close you are to these conditions
you sort of if you're epsilon away then
your constant depends on epsilon in the
worst case it is going to be square root
T these points unless you do these are
fancy stuff that Raymond and long do now
there is also this whole line of work in
the computer science literature but most
of these works actually use the fluid so
this LP that I showed as a benchmark so
they say hey this is an upper bound can
be sure that we get a certain fraction
of that or a certain loss from that and
one of the things you can prove is that
for these degenerate instances comparing
against the fluid is just truly a bad
idea you're always off by square root T
from this this this upper bound is
actually too weak in certain cases so if
you're comparing against that there is
no hope of getting
a constant regret this is fundamental
just because you kind of chose the wrong
benchmark okay so so how does all of
this tie in with the base selector so
how do what is an approximate Oracle
where do we construct one of these and
how do we sort of do this Bayesian
approach um and one idea would be okay
if we look at this resolved fluid LP you
could start interpreting this X I of T
as some predictor of what of how many of
these arrivals I take in in the exposing
the offline solution now if you think
about that then a kind of natural policy
to try is interpret this as an
approximate admission Oracle so it's
kind of giving you the probability of
sample paths where I accept this guy or
not and then sort of do thresholding on
that so instead of randomized like
instead of doing random admission
control you actually take this value and
threshold it at 0.5 and decide to accept
or not and essentially what we show is
that this policy actually has constant
rate so it's not that and this sort of
immediately kind of a implies that or as
part of the proof we can show that if
you had a policy which truly predicted
the object I was asking for that would
have worked but this kind of gives a
good enough prediction for peyote and
it's good enough to get the constant
regret
now as an aside this particular form of
the policy had been suggested before so
there was a work last year by my
colleagues by a colleague a tiger which
and Alessandro not aware for the single
resource case they proposed something
which is isomorphic to this although
they kind of had a different way of
thinking about it and they managed to
show a similar result now what what's
really difficult about showing something
like this is and the reason people were
doing randomized admission control is
that actually induces a martingale on
the budget sequence if if this doesn't
make sense it's not very important but
in some sense you are sort of
approaching the fluid solution in an
unbiased way whereas this is
deliberately adding bias into the
solution and so we somehow need to
analyze this random work where if the
random walks kind of like going off in
all sorts of direction then what
gurevich and a lot of managed to do was
they managed to construct some very
complicated martingale for this weird
work but it's not clear that any of
these approaches would extend more
generally so there is a more recent work
by buffoon Santi and Wang where they try
using these partial resolving ideas
where you say oh you resolved only at
certain times and do something careful
but they also kind of use some amount of
thresholding in their policy and they
they show this result for iid cases but
again the the sense is that what sort of
more important is that this resolving is
not the problem it is just that you need
to do you need to take this kind of
Bayesian approach look on the resolving
policy and do thresholding on that okay
so five minutes a little more than that
okay so give you a sense of how we show
these results oh this is gonna be a very
self impressionistic view of the proof
but the reason I'm doing this is we
actually believe that this idea of using
these kind of Bayesian approaches for
solving hard mdps could perhaps be
useful in much more general setting so
this is something Alberto and I have
been thinking a lot about and I'd be
very interested if people have ideas
about this and and as part of the work
what we essentially showed was there is
a way of constructing a very simple
coupling argument which gives you a
closed-form regrette solution for any
policy that you want to stripe so you
give
policy I will sort of give you a closed
form for the regret in some-odd
variational form but then you can try
and optimize it and essentially what we
did after that is we took this thing
which we call the compensated coupling
and have used it for downline packing
problem and and there the argument is a
little more bespoke itself it's
dependent on the setting but you can
show using fairly simple tools of LP
sensitivity and some Chernov bonds that
this this bound is actually small in the
case of online packing problems but I
kind of think this piece is more
interesting that there is a generic way
of getting regrette bonds and have
intrigued by where else this could be
applied so what is this idea so this is
what we call the compensated coupling
and the main idea is usually when you do
a coupling you somehow want to say that
hey your online policy should be coupled
together with whatever the offline
policies trajectories as long as
possible and occasionally it veers off
and you say ok oh that's a bad outcome
how can I bound it what we do in the
first sort of ways we instead ask the
offline policy to actually follow the
online policy so we are doing an online
policy and we're going to keep insisting
that the offline policy abandons
whatever it want to do and actually does
what we want it to do
now of course the offline is not happy
doing this it's not sort of getting the
optimal that it was getting and so what
we need to do at this point is we need
to offer a compensation so we need to
say that ok if I give you so much extra
reward for free are you willing to
follow my policy
so let's formalize the submit' so the
idea is if this was the offline the
value of the offline policy starting at
a certain state I'm going to define what
we call a disagreement state which is
essentially the set of sample parts
where the offline gist did not want to
do what we wanted to do so I want to
accept the current arrival here are the
set of sample parts in the future where
the offline did not want to accept this
current arrival and now the idea is at
least for the single resource if I force
it to accept the current arrival it
loses at most V max right like it loses
the best it could have done is by not
accepting the current arrival it accept
it's something in the future which gave
it a value which was the maximum value
and using this what you can do is you
can write a serve one-step recursion
where you say the value of the off
right now is less than whatever the
algorithm good because it's following
the algorithm plus for every sample path
where didn't want to follow I give it a
compensation of v-max you can tighten
this more but this this is enough for
our purposes and then you have the value
of the off line from the next period
onwards this is make sense so all we are
doing the only set of switch from a
normal coupling is instead of trying to
follow the off line we are forcing the
off line to follow what we are doing and
then just sort of trying to add up the
compensations for this and now if you
just write rate over this on a sample
path over all time and then take
expectations you basically get on the
left hand side so all of these
intermediate terms cancel out you just
get the expected value of V offline at
the beginning is less than the expected
value of whatever we got Plus this sort
of extra regret so what is this regret
term it's saying it's v-max times the
probability that by taking an action I
what's the probability of the mass of
sample parts where this action was a bad
idea and if you now think of what the
base selector is doing it's such it's
actually just minimizing this in a
greedy fashion so it's not optimal but
it's once you sort of write down this
expression it kind of seems like a very
natural thing to do if I'm adding up all
of these errors I could just try to
really minimize the error in each step
now this works for any online decision
problem so if you give me some any other
generic on lines of finite horizon or
discounted cars decision problem you
can't set up a kind of one-step coupling
of this sort and get a bound for the
regret except that it's going to be in
terms of like these measures over
disagreement sets and so then the game
sort of comes down to okay can we decide
what's the stopping rule and how do we
choose these disagreement sets and
that's something we've been trying to
think about a bit but I mean if anyone
else is interested or if you have your
pet online decision problem which you
think can be improved be very interested
in hearing about it so I'll give you a
brief sense of why this is small for the
online parking problem and I'll do it
for just a simple case of the single
resource and the idea here is at any
step so let's say we are at some time T
and I decided to reject the current type
so I looked at the current type and said
well
yeah I don't want to accept this guy now
I'm gonna compare myself again so if you
think of what the offline policy does it
has the full knowledge of the sample
part but it actually has a lot of extra
freedom so let's say it was only
accepting 10 out of 20 arrivals of type
I it could have chosen any of the 10 to
accept like you will get the same
solution whichever of the 10 that you
accept out of the 20 which showed up and
in particular I'm going to try and
compare myself against an offline policy
which accepts the first ten so it always
sort of front loads whenever it it
accepts this time now what this says is
if I made a rejection and I made a
mistake compared to the offline then the
offline must be rejecting everything
from now till the end of time for this
type so there is a self hidden
monotonicity in kind of online pattern
problems which is showing up here that
by making a rejection now I'm forcing
the offline to reject a lot of things
which is just exponentially unlikely and
you can do kind of the parallel argument
for if you accept and the serve short
story being the smaller of these two
probabilities is always exponentially
small in the Touro time and now if I
just keep picking the smaller
probability each time essentially all of
this is Somerville and I get constant
should read that's the entire proof and
it didn't need anything about ID it just
needed us to prove these sort of
probability bounds for the to go process
okay so that's mostly what they have so
what so what I was in talking about is
online packing problems but in some
sense this kind of bigger agenda being
if I want to think about these online
decision problems and I want to think
about the interaction with learning um
there's one way of approaching it which
is what if I just separate the learning
and the decision so I have these
extremely good black box predictors
which is learning from past data which
are doing bizarre things which I don't
understand but what's the right way of
sort of taking this these in and kind of
porting it into my online decision
problem and using these to get better
algorithms so what I showed was a very
specific case for online packing um in
some sense for what our work suggests
the sort of any problem where you have
some kind of monotony sitting in your
decision rules these sort of methods
will work very well because it's
exploiting the underlying monotonicity
but the regret bounds work for any
decision problem and kind of the
interesting research direction for us is
to think about okay what what happens in
other problems what happens in in kind
of supply chain settings what happens
for the case server etc so anyone's
interested in that yeah I'd be
interested talking about it but
[Applause]
so how would you how would you solve
this problem if the resource itself was
also randomly generated or yes sir what
happens with overbooking yeah so there's
sort of two answers one is what's the
algorithm the algorithm would if I knew
some if I had some predictor of which
each person whether they would cancel or
not I would simulate it I would see
whether I should sell it to this guy or
not and then just do it
it's possible that that the naive Bayes
selector doesn't work but there's
actually a kind of whole hierarchy of
these her Bayesian selection algorithms
that you can do and I am so it's not
clear which of these would work but the
good news is we kind of have these
regret bounds and it's it's worth sort
of looking at this and trying to tune it
to figure out what the repair so when
you have this NIT you know what I am
thinking is an idea has two components
one you look through the seats that are
empty exactly so you take all your
randomness all you take a predictive
model simulate it out see what you get
at the end of time and then just use
that to make your decision so so in some
sense that's the nice thing about this
paradigm which is that it's just
extremely simple it is truly just a
simulation if you have a generative
model you just it's plug-and-play
but it may not work in all settings like
we know there are settings where it's it
doesn't work as well as sort of slightly
better tuning but it's not clear that
there is no algorithm using this sort of
information which works but this naive
one this greedy policy will not work in
that setting there were few at the back
slide where you are talking about if I
understood correctly you talking about
sidestepping the need for the black box
today you could use lb yes sir I use
that as an approximation for the black
box predictor but what we really proved
in inside the proof is that we kind of
bounded it we sort of we found a bound
on how far that is from the true
prediction and then showed that it's
good enough so the true prediction is
it's just tough to characterize but this
we can characterize exactly and so well
so one criticism would be how do I even
I may not know this expected value of
the number of arrivals coming in so if I
have sort of a more complicated process
maybe this is the Markovian process my
generative model may know it but I don't
want to sort of go and like even finding
this expected value may be non-trivial
but sure if you know this you don't need
to do anything else I mean so the errors
would be additive so if you make an
error in this and then you take the
wrong decision so basically it would
just add up no that's at least in this
problem no that's the nice thing the way
we set it up something that seemed more
natural to me
what you're doing but what about instead
of taking the probability that they
accepting this is part of the optimal
solution is the expected solution value
that's what I should yeah okay that's
what I should take so that is truly yeah
so whatever suggesting is instead of
looking at the probability of making the
mistake I should look at the marginal
change in the value so that is a tighter
bound than this this is an approximation
of it so the only point being this is
purely technical but the lp sensitivity
arguments we had it was harder to bound
that quantity but it was oddly enough
easier to bound this kind of due to
these arguments but that is truly right
so what you really should be doing is
not looking at the probability of
accepting or rejecting you should be
looking at how much value you got if you
accept it how much value you got if you
rejected take the smaller of that and
then this is actually equal its an
equality in that case and then if you
can bound it that's yeah so that is the
troop based predictor we call this I
think the weak base predictor or
something like that but it's good enough
to prove this okay so
[Applause]